I'm going to help you get going with
your code and the first thing you're
going to need to do is set up your
development environment actually that's
the second thing you need to do the
first thing I'm going to have you do is
download the code that you're going to
be using in this course so to get the
code all you have to do is click this
download zip button here in the bottom
right corner when you do that it's going
to download the zip of all the code in
this repository to your computer when
you've downloaded it expand the zip and
you'll see all the folders for each of
the lessons here's lesson 2 lesson 3
lesson 4 and so on right now go ahead
download the zip for all the code for
the course